related but unrelated what about I'll
say girls women however you want to
describe them the ones that get pregnant
on purpose to keep the man
yeah so I I I've been waiting to try to
get my voice heard here
it does happen I know women that have
done it
I know men that have done that of course
yeah but but yeah
purposely coming inside a girl yeah to
get her pregnant so that she'll stay
with her wow
but a woman can still get rid of it the
man doesn't have a choice yeah but the
man can pressure them into keeping you
don't have to yeah
but you still literally don't have to
all right guys let her let her finish
yeah so this is this is a big thing and
um women will do it on private person it
doesn't matter what age you are what
background they think that's the way to
keep a man to retain a relationship to
perhaps even force a man into marriage
for some years that may not even last
and where you were talking about the
parents staying together
if that's what happens then then man
feels they've got no other choice but to
okay I've got married this girl she's
pregnant how long is that going to last
because they're then forced into the
situation they actually don't want to
live together
but then they've understand the
responsibility of co-parenting you know
if the woman has done that and the and
their father has tried and they're right
gonna marry you or I'm going to move him
with you we're having a child together I
don't like what you've done you know you
forced me into it but I'm gonna try
that's that's that's an exception I'd
say yeah
yeah it's a good question though they're
forced into living it living with each
other
for the sake of the children where you
said the children have to stay together
that's was he dating her first was he
like dating her was it a situation
there was
um
one of I say one of the gyms that I used
to go to
um
the the girl got pregnant on for purpose
thinking that would enhance a
relationship force them into marriage
and being able to keep the relationship
she was like dating him yeah they were
dating and
um they split up and all I can say is
you know there are exceptions uh the
most amazing father ever he took up his
responsibilities he absolutely adores
his son but he was forced into that
situation but all that did is you know
they end up breaking up did they did
they get married and then separate no
like they just agreed that they couldn't
make it work that they weren't
interested in each other they just
decided to raise his child but like
separately they were raising the child
separately she forced him into situation
to try and retain the relationship yeah
yeah that's an exception I think I think
the main the main thing the main point
here is like taking accountability of
your purposeful actions so what happened
to the relationship like what happened
to the relationship after like she like
basically baby trapped him like it broke
down yeah it broke it down
did they decide to like Force themselves
to live together
exactly no no none of that she forced
the situation she forced a situation
which obviously he was not happy about
but despite the situation and then
breaking up he stepped up as the one of
the most responsible amazing fathers
that you could ever meet whilst living
separately though yeah yeah okay
most of my words like most like the
majority of men yeah like we think
logically right and of course we got to
cover the basis I want to make sure that
my child can eat I want to make sure
that my child has a roof over there and
I want to make sure that my child is an
education the other Comfort bits we may
not all be so good at that but I'll say
that in no such situations speak until
women who are thinking of doing this
right now to trap a man that is the best
way to terminate your relationship
because that guy right there he may have
he may with patience he may have he may
have loved you for life right yeah but
trapping a man it's just it's almost the
most certain surest way to create an
enemy of like that guy will hate hates
hates her existence what loves his child
I'm saying so it's a thing where like
that's that's that's it's it's an
unproductive strategy of getting love
and it doesn't work because it's not
sustainable because you haven't built
that foundation and all of a sudden
you're in a really high pressure
situation where you're like oh my God
that's a horrible horrible thing you
know what it is that's that's I'm really
conflicted on that because I don't
really like rewarding bad behavior but
at the same time like I think it's about
the kids first I don't know because you
know what it is men are more accountable
for their actions so a man in that
situation is going to think do you know
what I'm not in her so
oh God I look after the kids you know
what I mean to do it I did it
there's also the point I mean I mean I'm
talking about this as a woman and I'm
I'm almost siding with a man talking
about this woman because I know people
that have done this where the woman on
purpose
will miss taking her pill and they're
you know whatever else she's doing she
will make the situation so it actually
happens how do you like did they tell
you this or how do you know they did it
well if we're talking about my um the
guy I know from the gym I don't know
what happened there but I do my most
recent ex
um you know we kept going back you know
on off on off and in between one of the
times where he end up dating someone
else then we got back together she
actually did that
she claimed she was taking her pill and
there was all these sorts of things
she tried to trap him
yeah she's stopped She yeah this is this
is my ex
um yeah she tried to chat for him and
she felt pregnant and um
he and I ended up getting back together
again for a millionth time
um and then
sadly which I would never wish on any
man or any woman
um
she must she miscarried but
um things I I don't I can't say I'm not
gonna go into medical things why things
happen but I do know that she was
am I allowed to say taking uh I don't
know what my last time you do she she
was taking drugs am I allowed to say oh
God I don't know what I can say yeah you
can talk about drugs
she she was taking a certain type of
drug
um
oh I can only guess I can't save a deaf
enough but I I could say that what she
was taking and her lifestyle and the
alcohol and the things that she was
doing may have this is May but
necessarily contributed to that stress
on the body will induce her and abortion
I mean there's a there's a reason Drake
puts hot sauce in his condo come on like
there's a reason like girls do that yeah
I didn't know you guys do you think that
a girl that lies to a man about being on
the pill
um and gets pregnant should be pursued
for fraud
no but it's disgusting it's disgusting
it's just it's disgusting behavior
let's say let's say it could be proven
like she admitted I told him I was
taking birth control yeah
and pretends to wear a condom and he's
not same thing that is essay so if you
pretend to take the phone you're not
that's it yeah you'll have his own name
but it's definitely need I think again
uh why did I decide to agree once with
pearl because now I seem to agree with
him on a lot I do think that's something
turning you no you're not turning me I
think we're just finding common ground
because there's gray areas in the world
as you know but I do think that there's
a lot of um things that in the
relationship between women and men where
women are actually favored and they do
then kind of get away with taking with
not taking accountability for certain
stuff so that is why I would then just
say from the moment go
pick somebody that will be a good father
to your children and a good man to you
and that doesn't mean he needs to be
with you that's all you need to do in
fact forget about the good man just let
him be a good father that's all you need
because that kid forget about your
relationship with him don't how would
the fraud thing work like just like
thinking out like uh and it makes sense
but is it like would the fraud payments
cancel out the um
yeah and then what would happen with the
baby
um I would guess the only way you could
prove it is a text if she told someone
yeah
I don't that's I would guess
um it's quite common but then I just
come to control it you said visually
recording her like what visually
recording you're taking yeah I have no
idea
a girl admitted it on national TV she
asked if she asked you was at a talk
show a couple years ago and she asked
the host if she should I think it was
one Wendy Williams maybe or maybe a
different host
and she basically asked them if she
would she could stop taking the pill she
she her husband doesn't want more kids
she does should she stop taking the pill
and just get pregnant and literally they
told her yes wow if the if the mind's on
showing like I don't know like if you're
that unsure that your wife is going to
do that he didn't want any more kids and
like I don't know I don't know the
situation but yeah he either gets a
vasectomy or he just starts wearing
condoms if you were that unsure
I don't think most men expect their wife
to die
he's watching TV he's like what if
you're managing that kind of it's
entrapment why are you there like if
you're like you you have an idea she
could do this so I'm gonna get the snip
or I think I'm like bro like why are you
with this stuff you shouldn't have to
think like that but you know what I
think on this subject yeah talking as a
guy I think there's there's also needs
to be um I guess more accountability
from from
from from both sides because I follow a
lot of This falls on the women 100
um because you know if you don't if you
don't want to take but if you don't want
to take pills then what you do I mean
like most guys would not go through the
same equivalent and there are those
options so I feel like it's about
balancing that in a way because yes I do
agree if you say on the pill and you
don't take the pill even the pill itself
is 100 so I mean so I think it's a bit
foolish to rely on a pearl on a pill and
with the expectation that you will never
have a child yeah and this just opens up
the the idea should men have to kind of
do something about contraception other
than just like wearing under them
because it's all the responsibilities on
the woman when women could have
temporary vasectomies oh my God we got
like we got 41 forms of birth control
you could get you can I don't you can I
don't you can get an
iuds from what exactly then where then
have the guys you sleep with wear
condoms yeah but a condoms don't know as
well okay then get a plan B yeah but why
does it have to always follow me like
why does it always have to be my body
yes we have the freedom it comes with
responsibility but men could also just
get a temporary vasectomy and it's
completely reversed because celibacy is
the safest bet thank you
okay you think you think a vasectomy
it's the same thing as birth control
hasn't got a side effect and me taking
loads of forms of birth control I could
gain weight I could be emotional I could
feel just like you could be celibate
come on celibacy is 100 yeah also we
also have the option of abortion we're
the ones that put them on child support
keep your pants locked men and women
keep your pants locked put a padlock
this is my set been my saying for a year
for a year or two now to anybody who
asked me put a padlock on your pants
that's a new saying padlock your pants
answer as well you could only just have
sex with people you are okay having a
child with yeah
like but that temporary vasectomy I mean
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible